The Joe Rogan experience I said on on on camera,
we had an email from somebody who said that his master could point pressure so
they could knock you out.
I got a great story about Tulsa with Amir.
Anyway,
I looked into the camera.
I said,
okay,
anybody in America you're watching right now,
if you have a person who gets,
who says that he can knock me out with a punch like it just pressing somewhere.
We invite them,
we pay him,
we pay his trip.
He can come on to show he can do it on camera on me.
He can knock me out.
I said,
it's a no lose situation for me because if it works,
I'm signing up to do that stuff.
But I tell you,
it's not gonna work.
We had this guy,
but uh,
you know,
a mirror progressive,
mostly where my buddy,
we,
we see these guys on stage and the touch guys,
right?
So one guy goes this thick,
this one,
they just fall back.
And then the guy said,
did you see his eyes roll back in his skill?
That means you was for real.
So I go to America,
this is going to be fun much this.
So these guys,
they come walking down after the.
I said,
okay,
dude did to me.
I want you to do it to me.
Wait a minute.
God said,
are you sure about that?
I show it to me.
I,
you know,
I want to know how to feel it.
And he goes,
you know what?
I could actually,
I got something better.
So we already steered away from it,
right?
So he says,
let me show you this.
And he walks over to his body,
they start talking to each other and then he walks away and in the corner he
stands like this,
like I mean crazy hiney run to his friend and he goes like this in emit air.
He stops and he flies on the ground.
So he threw like Kung Fu forehands I didn't touch him.
Does it touch him?
I go,
do it.
I'm sold.
Do that to me,
right?
I'm going to take you right now.
So I'm going to the corner.
And he goes,
yeah,
but you have to be a really angry.
I said,
excuse me?
Yeah,
really angry.
Otherwise it won't work.
I say your friend just did it right?
I say,
um,
I think I can better egg then your friend.
Don't worry.
I'll be in the zone.
Nobody will.
He says,
no,
because if it,
if you're not real angry,
it doesn't work.
It needs to be that balance.
So I knew it was his way out.
So I walked over to him and I'm standing like this.
I say kick me into pills.
And he says,
well,
give me the.
I say I'm really fucking pissed.
He didn't want to do it.
Needless to say,
I mean,
but they're idiots that truly believe that is true.
When
you stop and think about what an actual football player today,
310 pound man who can run like,
like literally like a track star of the 19 thirties,
you know,
when you stop and think about the kind of damage they can do and you sort of
look towards the future and extrapolate a thousand years from now,
2000 years now actually when this drastic changes happening just the last 50,
60 years,
it's unbelief.
When you look at the guys were a third larger
than they used to be ingested 50 years,
so you extrapolate that out.
Uh,
and of course there's genetic and physical limitations,
but as Jeanette,
as,
as nutrition improves and science improves and genetic engineering proves you're
gonna wind up in the future pro sports a couple of centuries now.
Pro Sport you're not.
I mean they're not even going to look human.
They're gonna look like a different species.
That's how I came up with the idea for the book is I used to be.
I used to do little stuff where espn when I was in college,
like manage the teams coming off the field or hold the dish and that kind of a
thing.
And I had was 126 pounds and Michigan,
Michigan State's at giant football game every year.
It's huge.
ESPN is there and my producer,
Al Kilian,
I'm on the headset with him and he's gotten me bringing the teams out of the,
out of their dressing room and then he starts screwing with me because I'm 19.
I don't know any better and he's in my ears.
And listen,
if they don't come out at the right time,
espn is going to lose $5,000,000 of advertising and that's gonna be on you.
And I'm like,
he was fucking with me because he could because I didn't know any better and I'm
like so stressed out and then let Michigan state out of the locker room at the
point in time and all these giant human beings are coming out.
And then as they're coming out,
they're running,
walking by the door to the Michigan locker room,
Michigan.
The door lock room door opens up and standing in the door.
Is Greg Scrap Knack?
You ever heard of him?
No.
He was six,
eight,
three,
three 60.
It was.
He was an,
it was a giant,
giant man.
Plus he's got all the gear on and I'm on and I'm like.
And I'm,
I'm a little tiny thing.
I'm freaking out.
I'm like,
Oh hell,
Michigan is going to come out.
He's like,
you don't let them come out of that locker room.
I don't care what you have to do.
And so I.
he's a giant.
He's six foot eight.
I'm five eight.
I'm 125 pounds and I and he goes to step out and I just put my hand right right
on the sternum.
I just stiff arm and what stopped right there.
You guys can't come out of that locker room yet and just
he looked confused was like,
who is this little person?
And he managed to wait and all the guys were behind him and he mans wait just
long enough for Michigan state to come out and then I got out of the way and
they came out,
but I had.
I wrote the whole concept of the book and that one moment,
the whole gfl series I had my hand on this guy's here.
My nose came up to his sternum and I remember thinking it's like he's a
completely different species than me and that was an after that I went home and
started writing that book.
Like what if we have different species playing football?
And the whole thing blew up.
From there.
People
feel about you taking off,
going to America to let everybody know about them and then flying back again.
It means this.
This must be so bizarre for them.
Yeah.
Well that's what's crazy at first.
Every other night,
well,
I've been to more than nine,
but the last time I went I went to nine different tribes and of pygmies,
a little nine villages.
Each one of them never seen a white dude before.
Uh,
so that scares them.
I mean,
there'd be times that it would take an hour,
maybe even sometimes a little over an hour before someone in that tribe.
Most of the time it was always women or children that would finally come up to
me and touch me to make sure they don't go through me like I was a spirit or a
ghost of some sort.
Um,
and then one person felt me and I'd play a game with them or something like
that.
Then more would,
I mean literally come out from hiding behind trees,
come out from,
from the forest.
Whenever I come in,
sometimes they would flee,
run,
cry kids like flailing on the ground,
like,
just freaked out by me.
Um,
but whenever I'd make friends with them,
uh,
then they would ask me one thing every place that I want.
No nine tribes.
Uh,
they asked me will I help them have a voice?
That was the thing.
They were like,
we have no voice here.
They're the only tribe not allowed to have their citizenship.
Um,
in Congo and like,
so they have zero voice.
Wow.
What a strange turn your life has taken that this is a,
you've gone from being on the house and the ultimate fighter,
you know,
competing in the heavyweight version of the show to now live in a grass hut in
the Congo.
What a,
that's a stranger alif hot rather strange journey.
You're on,
man.
Yeah.
To be honest,
I wouldn't change it.
For me,
actually,
booze was my savior because I was hanging out with a lot of dudes were doing
some serious,
serious drugs,
bad drugs,
and my whole thing was I don't want to be 60 years old and not.
So I always have this idyllic sort of retirement,
which I'm trying to get to sooner rather than later.
Now it's just like,
just sort of forgotten like little cove,
you know,
little code.
That'd be a neighbor and I'm sitting there at this school.
I'm going to send you this,
uh,
this article of this.
How old are your kids?
At?
Three and a one and a half.
Dude,
I got a foreign,
a party.
I'm going to tell you.
I'm going to send you the boys or girls.
Girls.
Okay.
We got a big lesbian super party.
I'm going to send you this article.
It's a fantastic article about a dude who was diagnosed with lymphoma,
lymphoma,
cancer,
like the worst cancer you can ever.
And and he was a Greek dude.
He grew up in America,
but like,
you know,
came here when he was three assumption.
So he goes back to Greece to this little island in the middle of nowhere and he
has to walk up this hill every day.
He goes to talk to his buddies,
drinking the wine,
he's eating the food from the farm or wherever and all of a sudden,
like five years.
But he was given like,
you know,
six months to live or whatever,
not even six weeks to live.
And,
and they said,
well,
you know,
what the fuck happened.
You didn't die.
And he goes,
you know,
I came here and I forgot to die because you know,
he's sitting there and,
and there's no stress.
And he's walking up the hill every day and he's,
he's drinking wine with his buddies and he's eating the food from the,
you know,
the fish from the bay and the fucking whenever.
And I sit there and I say,
you know,
now I'm looking at this shit.
So my idyllic retirements,
basically I'm stealing this guy who killed cancer by living this euphoric life
of I live on this little cove and I'm drinking my wine.
And I'm sitting out there and I'm just blissing out unreality now.
That's why I didn't get hooked to heroin.
That's why I didn't get hooked to fucking crack.
That's why I didn't get hooked all the shit to my boys got hooked too.
Because I always thought to myself,
if I fucking get hooked to this shit,
I'm going to have to a die or be fucking quit it,
and if I quit it,
guess what?
I'm never going to be able to sit on that fucking cove with my glass of fucking
wine sitting up there.
I'm being this blissful old Buddha,
right sophia?
And that's why I don't.
That's why I don't judge anybody,
because I'll tell you what everyone's trying to get through the day to get to
their God damn cove.
The.